on the mound for the twins tonight is
jose barrios two-time all-star in his
sixth big league season el tuve with a
home run in three consecutive games and
six in his last 11.
he's down quickly here as burrillo
strikes him out with a curve ball
throws that curve more than any pitcher
in baseball apparently the first one
gone it was unreal barrios with his
second strikeout both coming in the
curve ball
and two gone
as curveball again it starts out in the
strike zone where it ends up even if
bregman is able to make contact there's
not going to be any hard contact to be a
ground ball somewhere
your dan alvarez 23 year old cuban born
and a 1-2 pitch outside corner strike
three called in a curveball so barrio
strikes out three despite a walk astros
don't score 24-year-old louise garcia
made his big league debut last year
no two donaldson swings and misses for
the first down one on one out and up
comes nelson cruz
bounces one over the glove of garcia
waiting on the bag of zeltuve zeltouven
he turns it double play
kyle tucker
one for four last night left-handed
batting right fielder
tucker goes down the line to right that
is a backhanded attempt and a catch for
kirilov
alex kiraloff with a nice play for out
number two
kiriloff just extending gets that gloves
out glove out and outfielder trying to
keep that ball in line watch it and he
picks that right up off the ground it's
a heck of a catch
two on two out and a 2-2 to maldonado
tails a fastball to the inside corner to
get him lucky
four strikeouts for jose barrios through
two
that's curve diving play it first by
julie goriel that could have been extra
bases
who has by most measures been their best
hitter
lifted in the air
center field here comes
larnick and it's going to be gordon oh
calling everybody off
so he's getting some routine fly balls
making it look easy
oh wow that's a heck of a pitch
continues to be a good day to be a
pitcher man right tucker down looking on
the fifth k for barrios so this pitch is
down in the zone
and anytime you watch a catcher move his
glove and pull it up to a strike
he's telling you that's not a strike
only two hits against him through three
and two thirds the man up there right
now robel garcia has one of them yeah
who
takes strike three and mario's starting
to feel it a one two three inning his
first one tonight
here's mickelson oh
seven game hitting streak homer last
night
drives this sprawl to deep center field
mccormick racing back at the wall it's
off the very top of the wall and
ricochets back into left center field
wernicke into score on a sin oh double
and the twins break through in the
fourth
that is what he brings when he's right
big-time power
sending the ball to the wall and right
center to make it one-nothing timer on
the board for martin maldonado so no one
fly modonato hits it on the ground to
short takes a tough bounce on simmons
able to recover to get one and the
double play
simmons
643 twin killing
well simmons doesn't feel this cleanly
but he's got the slow running maldonado
and this ball is hit relatively decent
able to grab it still make a good throw
to polanco and polanco fires it up there
that's why you get in front of the ball
you see that ball didn't even get gloved
it just
hits simmons right in the thigh right in
the hip area one nothing game here in
minneapolis luis garcia back to the
mound facing nick gordon
three straight curves to get him but
this one scoots by maldonado gordon's
aboard to open the fifth
that's really the one thing holding this
astros team back right now is the
bullpen
nine hitter been roared vet runner takes
off montenado's throw bounces into
center field gordon has his second
stolen base tonight
about going to third he'll hang on there
runner in scoring position with one away
2-2
is lifted to center field back towards
the gap mccormick on the move won't get
there
extra bases for ward vet
into score is gordon
on an rbi double for ben robert just his
sixth big league hit it makes it two
nothing twins
polancos one for two today uses 2-2
that's drilled right center field
mccormick to the track it's gone
two-run home run for jorge polanco
and the twins lead it for nothing
really not much doubt on this thing at
all it's a fastball that just leaks out
over the play polanco gets a hold of
this thing beginning for jose this is
the heart of the order for the astros
2-2
curve ball he went around to go
on the seventh strikeout tonight for
jose barrios
this is the off speed and it's down in
that spot where you're throwing those
two fast balls bregman can't hold up
this thing bounces in front of the plate
and that's how good
barrios's stuff is tonight two up two
down in this six
how about right down the middle with a
fast ball there and alvarez stands there
and watches it go by jose barrios 91
pitches back out there for the seventh
julie guriel leads it off and jumps on
the first pitch hot shot to third josh
donaldson one pitch one out
there's tucker kyle tucker
swings at the first pitch sends it in
the air to left center field boarding to
the track at the wall it's gone
kyle tucker gets the astros on the board
with his 12th home run of the year and
it's 4-1 first two pitches of the indian
astros attack robel garcia who has power
he comes to the plate he's one for two
garcia now lofting the fly out of right
field
kiriloff turning and watching it's gone
back-to-back home runs and just like
that it's 4-2
garcia starting for carlos correa today
it's his first home run in an astros
uniform so the infield in polanco
hitting right-handed
line drive base hit center field
polanco's third hit of the game he's
driven in three
and minnesota leads it 5-2
bases are loaded for miguel no
fastball hit on a line to left brantley
makes a diving catch
and keeps houston in the game
the astros down to their last stop out
of the part of the order though they hit
the back-to-back homers
kyle tucker
1-2 coming
he struck him out and a 1-2-3-9 for
rogers to finish things off
the twins even this series hit a game of
peace winning at 5-2